good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today's message is prepare yourself for
success over to you dr. Sunday Agra
logic says is possible success is a
reality and but the fact is that only
people will get get the blessings of
success in life you know it's like life
is not free as it is in some extent or
in some cases if you look at it just on
the surface and you think that you will
see some people who are making it some
people who are doing a good job I mean
some people who are really making it in
life I think what makes these people
better than the other people and it's
like that's not really any much
difference but really there is a
difference it's sustainable that is
truly making it that is doing a good job
it is only because it's done something
right and the main work the major
condition or the major shame that a
person like that has done right is that
they have gotten themselves prepared for
the success that you now enjoy our
opportunities come only to people who
are prepared for them if you are not
prepared opportunities you will never
see them using the opportunities around
you people complain about the countries
they live in it will complain about
their leaders to complain about the
environment with unlisted they all
complain that there are no opportunities
in their countries and entities or from
their leaders or really any windows
countries even those cities there are
people who are having opportunities who
are you know being and trusted by life
by great positions or opportunities
because they are prepared for them so if
you want to be successful you have to do
the work to be prepared for it when it
comes to you success doesn't just land
on your lap opportunities don't just
open themselves up to you you have to do
the work it doesn't come by just sitting
on the couch and dreaming and thinking
and hoping
something's going to happen to you it
happens because you are out and you are
preparing and you are doing the work so
as an example I look at Lily who was one
of my self instructors still is and I
offered her a full-time opportunity to
quit her job and start her own business
as a new potential speaker with me and I
paid her to leave her job so she can
start this opportunity so she's getting
paces leave her job she's getting
mentoring for me to launch her own
business and a lot of people would think
well how do I get that opportunity how
do I get that chance to do it you're so
lucky that you get this thing that
nobody else gets but she's it the work
to prepare for it she was putting in
hustle and energy and heart and from one
of the first times that I met her and
had our conversation I said I want to do
something with you we're going to figure
out a way I get shown some kind of
business to happen together and she
might have thought I was crazy the first
time that we had that conversation
during the meeting he told me that he
really liked me and he wanted to start
some sort of business with me so my
first thought was wow he is so nice and
what an amazing confidence booster for
me but she worked at it and she prepared
and she put in hours and effort
consistently and that's the difference
if you look at anybody who's had major
success look at anybody who look up to
as an entrepreneur as an athlete as a
singer whatever you aspire to do there
is always a ton of hard work that goes
alongside it you will not get the
success you're after by just sitting on
the couch and when an opportunity does
come to you you have to say yes to it
before I offered Lily disposition I
actually offered a different position to
somebody else to a guy who I was going
to start a marketing agency with and he
said no he said he wasn't ready to quit
his job he didn't jump on that
opportunity and so I had the space to
offer to Lily if he said yes to that
opportunity three months sooner I
wouldn't have been able to give us to
Lily because my time would have been
taking up but he said no he's down his
corporate path and Lily said yes so when
those opportunities come and when
they're scary and when you're not sure
how it's going to work out do you seize
it or not or do you live the rest of
your life
at wondering what might have happened so
the question today today is I'm curious
what is the thing that you are doing
consistently to prepare yourself for
success how much are you working on your
dream on your goal every single day to
make sure that it happens leave it down
the comments below I'm super curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
credit to John Jenkins John thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and making that YouTube
video about it man I really appreciate
it and I thank you for the support I'm
glad you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I will see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event
[Music]
I picked up about 4:30 and 5m between
5:00 and 5:15 I am working on emails
catching up on news looking at the blogs
looking at the different opinions
because people just don't sleep I media
working 24/7 somewhere around the world
people are awake and working so he's
always constantly being bombarded with
requests information or just sometimes
news and so in the morning I wake up and
I you know take care of my mind and then
after that I work out and that's taking
care of my body and then I do meditate
before I go to work so that takes care
of my soul you know business is like a
war you have to be completely prepared
and unless you have mind body and soul
really all lady for it you just can't
fight that battle how often do you find
when you get on set people are like do
the Samuel do the same Jackson thing do
the 10ml Jackson thing that we know and
love
not often yeah I don't know what that is
I mean unless it's a [ __ ] like
eight times and you know well crap
display but um me I don't work I don't
really know what that is
or to me the Sam Jackson thing is I've
I've read the script you know I don't
know how many times and I've broken my
character down the way I learned to
break a character down in the theater if
there's sorts of material like for
George Washington Williams I'll go to
the source material and deal with that
but if not then okay it's up to me to
figure out who this guy is I can figure
out when he was born who his parents
were
what his educational background is
military if he has that what kind of
life experiences he's had how he feels
about this that or the other even down
sometimes to what kind of food eats you
know just because they're eating scenes
in the movie and I want to figure out
what I want to eat when I'm you know in
that particular scene and then from
seeing the scene what my relationship is
with those characters or what I'm trying
to accomplish in this scene that leads
to the next scene that leads to the next
scene that leads to the next thing
so what happens is the Sam Jackson thing
for me according to my agents and
managers is I'm so prepared when I show
up that I expect everybody else to be as
prepared as I am so when the director
does not have a shot list for that day
or directors floundering and trying to
figure out what he's doing he can ask me
and I can tell him you know because one
of funny things about movies is the
director is usually the person on the
film set it's got the least amount
experience of everybody their director a
director makes one movie every four
years every two years yes and I became a
director study that's what a good
directors for his 15 movies you know
everybody has done 15 movies last two
years you know so we all know you know
she's met any gonna be in the movie yeah
like you don't really need a shot yeah
so des des des she go what about that
restroom no that was amazing what are
you doin okay I digress somewhere but I
show up prepared so that immediately I'm
Jackson thing when you hire me you had
an actor who's going to show up who
going to know his lands gonna hit his
marks and do his best to make the other
actors around him better
absolutely I'm not gonna call shots for
you and I don't expect you to give me a
land reading and if you do you had to
Roma with doubt which might be the first
time that people in film necessarily
really appreciated what you were doing
your preparation for that was a strong
astronomical I'm amazing and so that has
the last pre-health question if I can
just ask you just to show the kind of
work that you're willing to do for even
I think it was eight minutes of screen
time which was deservedly rewarded with
an Oscar nomination but I mean that is
not a ton to work with and yet you made
the most of it how did you what did you
do to prepare for that one um well it's
based on a play so I read the
playing after I've read the play I said
I don't even understand this woman I
don't know why they've got all this
attention this woman wants a sacrifice
her son and uh and I had all the kind of
responses that you would have with the
character that you didn't understand but
it's being an actor you have to do
investigative work you have to you have
to make sure that when people are in the
audience they understand you and they
they ultimately feel something and so I
had to write a bio which ended up being
over a hundred pages I talked to people
who had seen the play because I was
doing a play at the same time and never
saw the play I read the script probably
I don't know how many times so I
literally study the script for four
months before I finally got it like I
had the aha moment and aha moment is we
always want to feel that decisions are
pretty we always want to believe that
decisions are easy and sometimes they're
a Sophie's Choice you know and sometimes
a person's motivations are absolutely
pure but to the outside eye they look
very dysfunctional and I probably you
know had the aha moment two days before
I even started filming and I was really
waiting for that aha moment because I
said I'm gonna be opposite Meryl Streep
and she's gonna tear me a new a-hole and
I do not want to look bad so um but I
had that aha moment but I did my I did
my work with that I can't emphasize that
enough you know because I I never want
anyone to dismiss my talent listen I may
get up on this screen and there are
times when I may stink because it's
occupational hazard
to not always be good but I never want
anyone to say that she's not an actress